>> Ed: ALL RIGHT.
AS SOME STATES BEGIN REOPENING
THEIR ECONOMIES, MANY RESTAURANT
OWNERS ARE CONCERNED THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO MOVE TABLES FURTHER
APART FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING,
MAKING IT EVEN HARDER FOR THEM
TO MAKE THE KIND OF REVENUES
THEY NEED TO BE VIABLE.
FOR MORE ON THIS -- WAIT, WE
HAVE KELLYANNE CONWAY.
WE WERE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
RESTAURANTS, WE DIDN’T HAVE
KELLY ON.
NOW WE HAVE BELLINGHAM.
WELCOME.
>> WE’VE BEEN HERE, I THINK WE
HAD SOME TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
>> THEY’VE HEARD THE PRESIDENT
AND DEMOCRATIC LEADERS TO HELP
THE PPP AND YET SOME OF THEM
CAN’T GET THROUGH TO THE SBA.
I CAN’T GET THEIR BANKS ARE
ACTUALLY LOAN THE MONEY.
WHAT’S YOUR ASSURANCES TO THEM
THIS MORNING THAT THE SBA ON THE
PRESIDENT ARE GOING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT AND WHERE ARE
WE ON A DEAL FOR MORE MONEY?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT AND I HEARD TODAY
FROM A LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS TEAM
THAT THEY ARE HOPEFUL WE CAN GET
THE DEAL THIS WEEKEND THAT DEAL
SHOULD INFUSE A WHOLE BUNCH MORE
CASH, BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, THESE
MOM-AND-POP SIDES THAT WE ARE
ALL HEARING FROM HIM, THAT THEY
WANT TO STAY AFLOAT.
THEY NEED TO HEAR THIS MONEY FOR
THEM TO MAKE PAYROLL AND COVER
SOME OF THEIR EXPENSES AND
OVERHEAD AND WE SEEN THESE
STORIES.
HARVARD GOT 9 MILLION OUT OF
THAT CARE IS ACT AND SOME PEOPLE
ARE VERY MUCH OBJECTED TO THAT.
THEY’VE GOT ABOUT A $41 BILLION
ENDOWMENT UP AT HARVARD AND I’M
SURE THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY
SHOULD PARTICIPATE IN IT AS
COMPANIES LIKE SHAKE SHACK HAVE
RETURNED THEY ARE MILLION DOLLAR
LOAN BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
THOSE WHO IT WAS INTENDED TO
HELP THE MOST ARE THOSE WHO ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST.
THE LOCAL STORES IN YOUR
COMMUNITY, NOT THE FRANCHISES.
THERE’S ALSO THIS NEW TRANCHE OF
MONEY WHICH WOULD BE ABOUT
75 BILLION MORE FOR HOSPITALS,
AND MORE FOR EMERGENCIES.
IT SUPPOSED TO BE MORE FLUSH
WITH CASH AND I FULLY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO KEEP ON APPLYING FOR
THE LOANS AND GRANTS.
>> Ed: SO THAT’S A BIG PICTURE
BUT LET’S GET SPECIFIC AND TRY
TO NAIL THIS DOWN.
THE WHOLE GANG, WHERE ARE WE AT
THIS HOUR AND ACTUALLY GETTING
THIS DEAL?
>> THE SECRETARY FEELS VERY
CONFIDENT AND YOU SAID THAT
YESTERDAY IS THAT A DEAL IS
HAPPENING.
LET’S BE FAIR, THIS PRESIDENT
HAS TAKEN IMMEDIATE ACTION EVERY
TIME ONE OF THESE RELIEF
PACKAGES RELATED TO THE COVID
HAS HIT HIS DESK, HE SIGNED IT.
THAT 2.2 TRILLION SEVERAL WEEKS
AGO, HE SIGNED IT IMMEDIATELY.
AND MAY I REMIND ALL AMERICANS,
THAT WAS PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
96-0, IT WAS BICAMERAL, BOTH
CHAMBERS, AND BIPARTISAN.
THIS IS NOT BEING OVERLY
POLITICIZED ON ITS WAY TO THE
PRESIDENT’S DESK.
ON THE WAY THEY ARE SOMETIMES IS
AND I WOULD SAY WHEN THE
MAJORITY LEADER IN THE HOUSE
SENDING LAWYERS THAT CONGRESS IS
NOW RECESSED UNTIL MAY 4TH
UNLESS THERE’S A COURT
EMERGENCY, FOLKS, WE ARE IN AN
EMERGENCY.
WE ARE HERE WORKING SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK OF THIS WHITE HOUSE AND
PEOPLE HAVE MOBILIZED PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SECTOR.
SO WE NEED CONGRESS TO GET BACK
HERE.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE AT HOME, THEY
SHOULD BE HERE IN WASHINGTON
GETTING THIS MONEY FUNDED.
WE ARE ALSO HEARING STORIES FROM
SOME OF OUR CATHOLIC SCHOOLS
WANTING TO SHUT DOWN, AND I
THINK SOME OF THIS MONEY SHOULD
BE INTENDED FOR OPERATIONS LIKE
THAT IF THEY QUALIFY UNDER 500.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
MOM-AND-POP STORES AND ALSO
THESE COMPANIES AND THE ITS
OUTFITS, THESE NONPROFITS THAT
PEOPLE AREN’T REALLY CONSIDERING
WOULD BE SO FINANCIALLY IMPACTED
BY THIS.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THEM
APPLY AS WELL AND HELP THEM.
>> Sandra: HEY, IT SANDRA.
OBVIOUSLY THE WHITE HOUSE IS
MONITORING THE SITUATION ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AS A PRESIDENT SAYS
HE BELIEVES THAT SOME GOVERNORS
OF SOME STATES HAVE GONE TOO FAR
WITH THE RESTRICTIONS ON
STOPPING THE SPREAD OF COVID-19.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE PROTESTS THAT
HAVE BEEN EMERGING, SOME OF THEM
EVEN CALLING FOR GATHERINGS ON
FACEBOOK.
IF MARK ZUCKERBERG RESPONDED TO
THAT CALLING AT THE SPREAD OF
HARMFUL MISINFORMATION.
THEY’VE AGREED TO TAKE SOME OF
THOSE CALLS FOR PROTESTS DOWN.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT SAYING
ABOUT THAT THIS MORNING?
THE PROTESTS ARE CALLING FOR THE
END OF SOME OF THE GUIDELINES
THAT HE SET TO BEGIN WITH?
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST WE WANT
PEOPLE TO ADHERE TO THE COVID-19
GUIDELINES.
PEOPLE SHOULD READ THOSE
WE NEED PHYSICAL DISTANCING OF 6
COVERING.
>> Sandra: AT SOME OF THE
PROTESTERS HAVE CLEARLY SEEN THE
PICTURES ARE BREACHING THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING LINE.
>> CORRECT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME SOME OF
THIS GOVERNORS HAVE PHYSICALLY
DISTANCED FROM COMMON SENSE.
IN MICHIGAN YOU CAN SMOKE GRASS
BUT NOT CUT YOUR GRASS, THIS
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE TO MANY
PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT DOMESTIC REBELLION,
I LOOK AT THOSE PEOPLE AND I SEE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND FORGOTTEN
WOMEN ECONOMICALLY.
THEY SAY I’M IN A LOW INFECTION
AREA, I’M ASYMPTOMATIC AND NOT
EXPOSED, I WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
LET’S BE FAIR.
TODAY IS APRIL 20TH AND WE HAVE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
RIGHT NOW STARING AT THEIR BILLS
IN MAY.
HOW ARE GOING TO MEET THE BILLS
IN MAY?
THE BASIC NECESSITIES IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLD.
AND THEY ARE SAYING I WANT TO
GET BACK TO WORK.
SOME OF THEM ARE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE
POPULATIONS AND PROTECTING THEM.
THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES ARE OUT
THERE THAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE
HEARING TWO.
>> Ed: WE HAD DR. PETER HOTEL
IS ON EARLIER AND EVERY EXPERT
INCLUDING HIM SAYS, WE GOT TO
INCREASE IN RAMP-UP TESTING.
BUT HE TOLD US HE WANTS TO ASK
YOU DIRECTLY AS A MEDICAL
EXPERT, IS THE WHITE HOUSE -- HE
UNDERSTANDS AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND, MAYORS AND GOVERNORS
ALL CARRY SOME RESPONSIBILITY
HERE BUT HE SAID IT’S GOING TO
TAKE THE WHITE HOUSE TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK BY PUSHING
THE CDC TO HAVE SOME NATIONAL
GUIDELINES AND STANDARDS SO THAT
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS AND EVERY
STATE AND MUNICIPALITY KNOW
WHAT’S GOING ON WITH TESTING.
AS THE WHITE HOUSE GOING TO TAKE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY?
>> I HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS THERE.
FIRST OF ALL TESTING IS THE MOST
FREQUENTLY ECHOED WORDS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON TESTING.
FIRST THERE IS DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING.
THAT TESTING WE HAD ABOUT 85,000
A MONTH AGO AND NOW WE ARE AT
4 MILLION, WE WILL BE AT
5 MILLION BY THE END OF THE
MONTH SO THAT’S WENT UP
SIGNIFICANTLY.
ITS RAMPED UP IN THE TYPE OF
TESTING THAT YOU SEE AT RUTGERS
AND SALIVA TESTS, EASY TO THE
RAPID ABBOTT TESTS.
THE FDA IS APPROVING DIFFERENT
TESTING SO MORE PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS THAT.
IT IS ALSO SURVEILLANCE TESTING
FOR SURVEILLANCE AND CERTAINLY
ALSO SEROLOGY TESTING THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AND I THINK THE
GREAT NEWS I HAVE FOR YOU TODAY
IS IN ABOUT 20 MINUTES THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
LEAD A CALL WITH OUR NATIONS
GOVERNOR.
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
TESTING.
ONE THING DR. BIRX IS
EMPHASIZING TO THESE GOVERNORS
IS, WE DID ABOUT 150,000 TESTS
PER DAY I THINK, WE CAN DOUBLE
THAT IF WE CAN RAMP UP THAT
CAPACITY.
DR. BIRX HAS PUT TOGETHER A MAP
THAT SHOWS YOU WHAT YOUR TESTING
CAPACITY IS IN YOUR OWN STATE,
HOPING THAT THESE PRIVATE LABS,
EVERYBODY KNOWS.
WE ARE GOING TO SUPPLY THEM,
WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN YOUR STATE,
WHICH DO YOU ACTUALLY NEED TO,
WE WANT TO SUPPLY THE NEED AND
NOT THE ASK.
DR. BIRX WAS TELLING US TODAY
THAT WE HAVE NINE PLATFORMS AND
A THOUSAND LABS AND THAT FOR
BOTH THE ANTIBODY AND NUCLEIC
TESTING, YOU NEED SPECIFICITY
AND SENSITIVITY THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON NOW.
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT THAT IS
WHERE THIS IS HEADED NEXT.
IT’S NOT A PERFECT SYSTEM BUT
WE’VE BEEN BUILDING THAT
ECOSYSTEM AROUND THE CLOCK.
>> Sandra: WAS ALSO DIFFICULT
TO EXPECT IS JUST EXACTLY HOW TO
REOPEN THE COUNTRY AND GET THE
ECONOMY GOING AGAIN.
IT’S AN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
DECISION.
>> I WOULD REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THERE’S A THREE PHASED APPROACH
TO OPENING AND WE HAD PUBLISHED
THAT LAST WEEK.
EVERYONE CAN ACCESS THAT, I’M
SURE IT’S ON WhiteHouse.gov
AND FoxNews.com, IT’S EASY TO
ACCESS.
THE REASON THERE ARE PHASES IS
BECAUSE THIS IS DATA DRIVEN AND
NOT DATE DRIVEN.
WE HAVE FROM THE BEGINNING BEEN
LISTENING TO THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND SCIENTISTS AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
HE THINKS THERE IS ENOUGH
TESTING FOR PHASE ONE AND, IF
YOU ARE LOOKING AT PHASE ONE WE
CAN WITH THAT.
WE ALL RECOGNIZE THE BALANCE
THAT WAS NECESSARY, AND, IF YOU
LOOK AT THOSE THREE PHASES, IT’S
NEVER INTENDED TO JUST TURN ON
THE BUTTON, LIKE A LIGHT SWITCH.
THIS IS MORE GRADUAL AND IT
DEPENDS ON INFECTION RATES,
VENTILATOR CAPACITY IN YOUR
AREA.
IT ALSO MATTERS IF YOU WERE EVER
EXPOSED.
IF YOU ARE ASYMPTOMATIC.
IN ONE WORKPLACE YOU MAY HAVE A
PERFECTLY HEALTHY 28-YEAR-OLD
MALE WHO LIVES ALONE WHO WAS
NEVER EXPOSED, IS ASYMPTOMATIC,
HE MAY BE IN A DIFFERENT
SITUATION THAN A COLLEAGUE WHO
IS 50 YEARS OLD AND HAS BEEN
EXPOSED OR IS ASYMPTOMATIC.
I’M SURE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM BUT, YOU SEE WHAT
YOU ARE DOING CABINET WIDE AND
ADMINISTRATION WIDE, AND THE
MEAT-PACKING INDUSTRY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT INDUSTRY BY
INDUSTRY AND GEOGRAPHY BY
GEOGRAPHY AND NEVER SUGGESTING
IT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
SEE THAT.
THE GOVERNORS WANT THE LAST SAY
AND, THEY SAY WHETHER OR NOT TO
REOPEN THEIR ECONOMY, BUT THEY
WANT TO DELEGATE AND ADVOCATE,
CAN NAVIGATE ALL THE CALLS WITH
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
I HEAR AN AWFUL LOT OF ELABORATE
COMPETITION AND SOME GOVERNORS
GO TO OTHER NETWORKS BUT THERE’S
BEEN A GREAT DEAL OF RESPONSE
AND COLLABORATION AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE AS WE GRADUALLY REOPEN
PIECES OF THE ECONOMY.
>> Ed: WHAT ABOUT THE
COLLABORATION AND OR LACK
THEREOF?
AMONG OTHER THINGS SHE SAID THE
PRESIDENT IS A WEAK LEADER AND
HE HAS FAILED IN THE CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE.
YOU SAID?
>> IT WAS SUCH A DISAPPOINTING
INTERVIEW FROM THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE WAS SITTING IN HER
HOME NOT FEELING ISOLATED OR
ECONOMICALLY DESPERATE LIKE SO
MANY AMERICANS ARE, I THOUGHT IT
WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR HER TO
JUST NAME CALL AND DISPARAGE THE
PRESIDENT PERSONALLY INSTEAD OF
SAYING I’M GETTING CONGRESS BACK
TO WORK THIS WEEK SO WE CAN GET
MORE MONEY FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS TO STAY AFLOAT.
FOR THEM, IT’S NOT A MATTER OF
PROSPERITY, AND SURVIVAL RIGHT
NOW.
AND IT SHOULDN’T JUST BE
SURVIVAL OF THE FITTEST, THAT
SHOULD NOT BE DARWINISM OR
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE YOU ARE A
SMALL BUSINESS WHO IS GOING
INVENTORY BY INVENTORY OR
PAYCHECK BY PAYCHECK, WE SHOULD
BE HELPING THEM.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
PPP AND I FELT THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE TO SAY,
SMALL MINDS TALK ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE COME THEY DON’T TALK
ABOUT BIG ISSUES.
I FELT IT WAS INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING THAT INSTEAD OF
HERS SHOWING BIPARTISANSHIP AS
WE’VE SEEN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN SO MANY WAYS, HAVE
YOU EVER SEEN THE COUNTRIES
PEOPLE OR BUSINESSES MOBILIZE IN
SUCH A POSITIVE WAY AS WE HAVE
IN THE LAST FIVE WEEKS, SANDRA
AND ED, IT’S REMARKABLE TO SEE
AS A MOTHER OF FOUR SCHOOL-AGE
CHILDREN, IT’S BEEN FANTASTIC TO
POINT OUT IN A COMPLETELY
NONPOLITICAL FASHION HOW MANY
AMERICANS AND HOW MUCH AMERICAN
BUSINESSES IN THE VOLUNTEERS
HAVE STOOD UP, OFFERING TO HELP
WITH THE FOOD BANK, OFFERING TO
HAVE THEIR PARKING LOTS WE STAND
UP FIELD OF MEDICAL HOSPITALS OR
TESTING SITES.
THEN WE HAVE THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE WHO WAS ALWAYS CALLED SO
SMART AND POWERFUL NOT SAY, I
NEED TO MAKE SURE THE MONEY IS
THERE.
>> Sandra: JUST A FOLLOW UP ON
SOME OF THE VIDEO THAT WE’VE
BEEN PLAYING WHILE YOU’VE BEEN
SPEAKING, THIS AN AREA OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE WE ARE SEEING
THESE PROTESTS.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
ABOUT THAT THIS MORNING, IS HE
CONCERNED THAT WHILE THEY MIGHT
BE PROTESTING WHAT THEY SAY OR
SEE ARE THE RIGHT REASONS TO GET
BACK TO WORK, OR THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE OVERLY RESTRICTED, IS
THE PRESIDENT -- IS THE
WHITE HOUSE TASK TEAM CONCERNED
THAT THEY MIGHT BE SPREADING THE
VIRUS AT THE SAME TIME WHILE
THEY ARE GATHERING?
>> LOOK, WE TOOK GREAT ACTION,
UNDER TREMENDOUS CRITICISM
INCLUDING BY FULL ON MEMBERS OF
THE " #Resistance IN THE
MEDIA, HE HAS SAVED LIVES BY
DOING SOME.
HE’S HAD AN ADDITIONAL 30 TO
SLOW THE SPREAD SO WE ARE SECOND
TO NO ONE IN TERMS OF SAYING, DO
WHAT YOU MUST TO SLOW THE SPREAD
AND KEEP IT THAT WAY.
BUT, AND WE WANT TO LIVE WITH
THE VIRUS WHILE WE ARE DOING
TESTING, THERAPEUTICS, AND WHILE
WE ARE DEVELOPING A VACCINE.
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING THIS
STATE AND THAT COMMUNITY, THOSE
KINDS OF WORKERS IN THAT
INDUSTRY, GO GO GO.
BUT CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKERS HAVEN’T STOPPED WORKING.
OUR TRUCKERS, OUR SANITATION,
OUR AMAZING HEROIC HEALTH CARE,
WORKERS AND FIRST RESPONDERS,
THAT GIVES YOU A GOOD ROAD MAP
AS TO HOW TO REOPEN PIECES OF
THE ECONOMY SENSIBLY AND
SMARTLY.
>> Sandra: AND WE KNOW AS YOU
SAID THE GROUP OF GOVERNORS WILL
BE MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
THIS MORNING.